it's a desperate situation
from branches to plastic containers of
water locals are using whatever's at
hand to smother the flames
we're fighting fire to protect at least
the houses we evacuated the elderly and
we stayed as you can see
as you see there are fires everywhere we
have not seen the government here the
people are acting as the government long
live the civil protection teams
algeria's kabil region is known for its
lush mountains and forests but scorching
summer temperatures have reduced the
trees to kindling
it's one of 16 provinces in the north
african country that's been hit by
wildfires since monday
but many villages are isolated difficult
to reach and suffer from severe water
shortages
as homes burn and cars disintegrate
many people have escaped to shelter in
hotels and schools
some soldiers sent in to help were
reportedly cut off from safety by the
fires and succumbed to the flames
others badly injured with burns
we have three deaths here and four in
the other village the hospital is full
algeria's president abdulmajid taboon
tweeted condolences to the soldiers
families
the interior minister has blamed
arsonists for the fires
but so far hasn't provided details
i can't tell you for beating the fire
but we're fighting it with all that we
have
as a thick blanket of smoke consumes
kabil's mountains and the skies tinge
amber
residents fire crew and soldiers
continue to battle the destructive force
of the fires
laura burden manly al jazeera